[Music]
fleeing a war zone with her young son
boris and her 78 year old
wheelchair-bound mother janna has been a
nightmare for olga voro
it's just horrible that's why we're on
the way
the russian military bombed her
neighbor's house and despite the
challenges of evacuating olga realized
civilians were being targeted
deliberately and she had to get out to
survive
they started to bomb just normal houses
of people
not really anything else their difficult
journey led them to moldova where
refugees are welcomed well they're our
neighbors the generosity of this small
and relatively poor country is
unmistakable
moldovans have opened their hearts and
their homes to those fleeing the war
look it's really heartbreaking
some like anatole malenka have traded
their jobs to volunteer working around
the clock to feed transport and house
tens of thousands of people well look we
saw a need we actually heard bombings
explosions we realized it's happening on
the other side so we decided at least as
much as we can as long as we are safe we
want to at least do something good so
this daycare is now where local women
are cooking for the masses in an effort
that far outscales their resources there
is a fear among volunteers we spoke to
they could run out of food as more
people arrive
donation centers in the capitol are
overflowing with support but handing the
supplies out is a challenge with
refugees scattered across many camps and
private homes the issue is trying to get
the district to get it distributed
properly get it in the hands of the
people that need it for some the support
is appreciated but the strain is too
much
we found 18-year-old mom violetta
heading back into ukraine with her
11-month old baby eva
she knows the risks of going back she
says but she cannot bear to be without
her husband
and would rather be together as a family
whatever comes
the number of refugees here in the
capital of kishana has reduced in recent
days because they are now being moved to
other parts of europe but there is fear
that that could pick up substantially in
coming days if there is an attack on
odessa those numbers could spike to as
many as one million refugees crossing
the border into moldova donna mercedes
thanks